♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SO, THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT SPENDS
NEARLY $90 BILLION TRAINING THE
AFGHAN ARMY, AND YET THAT ARMY
COLLAPSED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
WELL, A 2009 REPORT FROM "THE
GUARDIAN" SUGGESTS ONE POSSIBLE
CONTRIBUTE AND FACTOR: MANY
AFGHAN SOLDIERS WERE HIGH ON THE
JOB.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE A HELMET ON.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A RIFLE RIGHT
NOW.
HOW IS HE READY?
>> IT'S LIKE HAVING 26 KIDS I
HAVE TO WATCH AFTER.
IT REALLY IS.
>> READY WOULD BE ON THE ROAD,
READY TO MOVE AT 8:30.
>> I THINK OF THE INTRODUCED
DRUG TESTING TO THE AFGHAN ARMY,
WE WOULD LOSE PROBABLY THREE
QUARTERS TO MAYBE 80-85% OF THE
ARMY.
>> IT REQUIRES TELLING THEM
ALMOST 30 TIMES, DON'T DO THIS,
DON'T DO THIS, DON'T DO THIS,
DON'T DO THIS.
>> COME ON, LET'S GO.
>> Tucker: SO THAT VIDEO IS
DEEPLY OFFENSIVE TO PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, WHO HAVE TO COVER UP
THE WASTE THAT THEY HAVE
PERPETRATED IN OUR NAME OVER 20
YEARS, BUT IT'S REAL.
AMERICAN SOLDIERS IN MANY CASES
HAD TO TEACH AFGHAN RECRUITS HOW
TO READ AND WRITE AND OPERATE
BASIC EQUIPMENT.
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS, 90% OF
THOSE WHO ENLISTED WERE
ILLITERATE.
THAT'S WORSE THAN THE NATIONAL
RATE OF LITERACY.
FOX NEWS STEVE HARRIGAN
RECOUNTED HOW INEFFECTIVE OUR
LITERACY TRAINING WAS TODAY.
WATCH.
>> I REMEMBER GOING TO
GRADUATION, TRAINING CLASS OF
AFGHAN SOLDIERS, AND THEY ALL
SPUN THEIR DIPLOMAS AROUND
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHICH
LETTERS WERE UP.
NONE OF THEM COULD READ AFTER
GRADUATION.
ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN AROUND
AFGHAN NATIONAL GOVERNMENT
SOLDIERS KNOWN THAT YOU HAVE TO
DO A MISSION BEFORE PAYDAY,
BECAUSE WHEN PAYDAY COMES, THEY
ALL DISAPPEAR.
>> Tucker: SO THIS WENT ON FOR
20 YEARS, AND FOR SOME REASON,
MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW THIS.
MICHAEL TRACY IS AN INDEPENDENT
JOURNALIST WHO WRITES FOR THE
SUB STACK AND INTERVIEWED AFGHAN
VETERAN MUST MONTH WHO CALLED
OUR ENTIRE PRESENCE IN THE
COUNTRY A BIG MONEY FUNNELING
OPERATION.
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON, SO
IT SOUNDS LIKE, FOR THOSE OF US
WHO ARE SCRATCHING OUR HEADS AND
ASKING, YOU KNOW, WHY DO WE KEEP
DOING SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
WORKING, MAY BE MONEY AS PART
THE ANSWER?
>> WELL, THE VETERAN THAT I
INTERVIEWED, WHO WAS A MEMBER OF
THE JOINT COMMAND THAT OVERSAW
THE SUPPOSE IT TRAINING EQUIPPED
MISSION, THAT WAS EXACTLY HIS
THEORY.
HE SAW THAT THESE DEFENSE
CONTRACTING BEHEMOTHS, WHICH
TOOK AS PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
THE DATA THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PROVIDED TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
AS TO THE STATUS OF THE TRAINED
AFGHAN SECURITY FORCES, THAT
DATA WAS ESSENTIALLY CONCEALED
FROM HIM AS A MILITARY OFFICER,
WHO WAS CHARGED WITH FOLLOWING
THAT PROCESS DAY TODAY.
SO IT WAS A SYSTEMIC GRAFT AND
CORRUPTION AT THE VERY HEART OF
THE INTERVENTION, AND THE REASON
WHY I THINK, AS YOU SPECULATE,
EARLIER IN THE SHOW, THAT WE SEE
SUCH STRANGE OUTBURST OF
INDIGNATION IS BECAUSE THERE ARE
SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA, IN
THE POLITICAL CLASS, AND ACROSS
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM OF ESSENTIALLY
AMERICAN GOVERNMENTAL PROCESS,
THAT BENEFITED PERSONALLY,
FINANCIALLY, REPUTATION ONLY,
FROM WHAT IN ESSENCE WAS A
FAILED INTERVENTION, AND THERE
ARE PLENTY OF GUYS WHO WERE ON
THE FRONT LINES WHO SAW IT
FIRSTHAND, WHO WILL ATTEST TO
THE REALITY OF THAT FAILURE,
EVEN IF THEY ARE THE GENERALS
AND THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISORS AND THE PEOPLE WHO SIT
ON CORPORATE BOARDS NOW AND
PONTIFICATE ON TV, EVEN IF THEY
HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION.
THIS WAS AN EPIC, COLOSSAL
FAILURE, AND FRANKLY, IT'S
INCUMBENT ON THE ENTIRE
BIPARTISAN POLITICAL CLASS,
WHICH FACILITATED THIS
NIGHTMARE, TO REFLECT AND TO
FIXATE NEEDLESSLY ON THE
LOGISTICAL DETAILS OF THE
WITHDRAWAL, IT'S OPEN TO
CRITICISM JUST LIKE ANYTHING A
PRESIDENT DOLLARS, BUT, BUT, I
THINK THAT SHOULDN'T DISTRACT
FROM A THOROUGH SELF-CRITICISM
AS TO HOW WE EVEN GOT THERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE COME OVER 20
YEARS UNDER PRESIDENTS OF BOTH
PARTIES.
>> Tucker: I READ YESTERDAY,
THE TOTAL COVERAGE ON THE
NETWORK NIGHTLY NEWS OF
AFGHANISTAN FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS WAS ESSENTIALLY ZERO.
I MEAN, PROSTATE HEALTH GOT TEN
TIMES AS MUCH COVERAGE AS THE
OCCUPATION OF AFGHANISTAN.
DO YOU HAVE ANY HOPE THAT WE
WILL GET A CLEAR ACCOUNTING OF
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING THERE
FOR DECADES?
>> OH, YEAH, I'M SURE ALL OF THE
OPERATIVES ON TV THESE PAST FEW
DAYS WHO ARE POSTURING AS OF
THOUGH THEY ARE THESE PURE
HEARTED HUMANITARIANS WHO ARE SO
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT AFGHAN
WOMEN AND GIRLS, I'M SURE THEY
WILL BE LEADING THE CHARGE FOR
THIS AFTER ACTION REPORT ON HOW
THE AMERICAN GLOBAL HEDGE ENTITY
SUFFERED THIS BLOW.
I WOULD DEFINITELY TRUST THEM
AND THEIR JUDGMENT TO OVERSEE
THAT PROCESS.
I MEAN, SO MUCH OF THE NARRATIVE
IN THE MEDIA -- AS REGARDS TO
THIS WITHDRAWAL -- IS A TOTAL
JOKE, AND IT IS SELF ABSOLVING
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO HAD A DIRECT
ROLE IN ENABLING SUCH A SYSTEMIC
FAILURE.
>> Tucker: SELF ABSOLVING.
THAT IS A GREAT WAY TO PUT IT
AND ABSOLUTELY TRU